JERZY FORYCIARZ: Good
morning, everyone.
I hope you enjoyed the
first part of this day
as much as we did.
So we've got to talk about
hybrid monitoring and logging.
But before we get
started, I would
love to ask everyone
to stand up for a bit.
Could you please stand up?
All right.
We're going to have around
a very quick survey.
Those of you running
Stackdriver in production,
you may sit down.
Big number.
All right, those of you using
multiple monitoring and logging
tools in production,
you may sit down.
OK.
And all the rest,
of those of you
running monitoring
across clouds,
and some other environment,
being on prem or out of cloud,
you may sit down.
Thank you.
That was fun.
OK, so here's the contract.
Over the next half
an hour or so, we're
going to talk about what
do we mean by hybrids,
how do we let you monitor hybrid
environments, And at the end,
we're going to get
you a great walk
through of the features of a
solution that lets you do so.
And we are going to run a demp
with a practical application.
With this, let's get started.
So when we talk about
a hybrid environment,
we're specifically thinking
this very picture, right.
You have a set up
somewhere, be it on-prem,
be it some other cloud, and
set up in the cloud like GCP.
And what you really
want to do is
to be able to run your
workloads in the same way
and monitor them
in the same way.
So ideally, that would be
the very same monitoring
and logging solutions with
the very same dashboards
and very same alerts that
you would apply here, here
meaning in a cloud,
and on premises
so that you can monitor
and see what's happening.
But even more convenient would
be a situation like that,
where you have just one point
in which you can compare
how your system is doing,
which is specifically important
if you're running the
workloads with some spill
over between one and the
other, and you really
want to understand
what's happening.
More about it in a
demo in a second.
All right, so
before we go there,
just realize Kubernetes brought
this enormous opportunity
of doing exactly
this, because the way
of obstructing your
workloads on top
of the physical
infrastructure lets
you look at your deployments
and your workloads
in the exact same way.
So how does the data flow
from the darkest corners
of Kubernetes?
Let me get you a very
quick walk through.
First, Kubernetes
per se does not
have any sophisticated built in
monitoring and logging system.
However, many components depend
on monitoring data, right,
so things like Horizontal
Pod Autoscaling, scheduler,
kubectl top.
And node itself,
they need metrics.
So this has been
solved by Kubernetes
as by itself for itself
through something
that we call Metrics API.
This way, Horizontal
Pod Autoscaling
can actually work using some
internal metrics on the CPU
utilization scheduler.
It can make reasonable decisions
on where to place the pods,
right.
And kubectl top gets you
the proper information
on what's really happening.
So the Metrics
API is implemented
by the Metrics Server.
Metrics Server is technically
scraping the nodes
in the search for
the metrics data.
That's what's happening there.
So let's have a look at the API.
And you look at that,
it's super simple, right.
It actually has three components
through the definition.
And one is on the
level of nodes,
the second one is on
the level of pods,
and the third one is just a list
of containers inside of both.
And it really specifies
only two pieces
of the information, right,
a timestamp, a time window
and the usage data.
So this is what
we're collecting.
This is what the
Metrics API is actually
getting out of Kubernetes.
Now, let's have a closer look
what's happening in the nodes,
right.
Well, at the nodes, you
obviously have a kubelet.
A kubelet is consulting with
a cAdvisor to scrape data
from all of the
system components.
Like Docker, like ATCD,
like all other pieces,
like system level pods
that need to be monitored.
And all of that data
is then extracted out
into the summary API.
So through this, well, we have a
system that is self-sufficient.
We call it a Core
Metrics Pipeline.
This is the system that
lets Kubernetes run.
But in order for you to run the
workloads, to run your setup,
you actually need
more than that,
and for this, you need
external solution.
We call it third party
applications, right.
These solutions, there
are many of those.
They work in one of two ways.
They either work
in a push model,
in which the data and metrics
collected gets written directly
to the monitoring solution.
Or they work in a pull model,
where the monitoring solution
is scraping the data
from the endpoints.
It's hard to say
which one is better.
There are solutions
that work either way,
and we are going to walk
you through both of these.
So in order to look
at the data, you
can look at two
possible solutions.
We're going to walk you
here through Prometheus
and Stackdriver.
Prometheus works in a
pull mode, Stackdriver
works in a push mode.
So when you look at the
structure of Kubernetes,
you have the nodes on the bottom
with kubelet, the key component
of the control of a system.
Then you have pods, and then you
have Kubernetes Master, right.
At the node level, you
have Node Exporter.
Through Node
Exporter, Prometheus
gets the data of like what's
really happening there,
CPU utilization,
amount of memory,
all of that kind of set.
And then there is pods.
Pods, as we just
discussed a minute ago,
get the cAdvisor to go
get all of the data of how
pods are behaving.
And on top of that, you have
all of the natural components
of the Kubernetes as a system
that are naturally reported
in a Prometheus format.
And this is everything
from the Kubernetes API
through the containers' runtime,
kubelet stutters, et cetera.
All of these components, in a
very natural and native way,
get reported by the
Prometheus server that
sits on each and every node.
So now that we
have it, let's have
a look at how this is
happening in Stackdriver.
So Stackdriver has a
layer of three APIs.
The first one is the
Stackdriving monitoring API.
It has a heapster
through which it's
collecting some of the data.
But in fact, it also has
a Stackdriver Prometheus
collector.
So Stackdriver
Prometheus collector
is capturing all of the
data that Prometheus
is scraping from all of
the system components,
like whatever
number, 500 or 200.
So anything that is happening
in the Kubernetes layer
can now be accessible
through the Stackdriver.
And then there are
two more components.
One is the metadata API
that writes the data
through an agent
that gets deployed
on each and every note.
And the same deployment
of a daemon set
is also deploying
another fault that
is called Stackdriver
logging agent that
is collecting the logs.
So through this,
you have a full set.
This works in a push mode.
And now when you look
at that holistically,
you have Prometheus clients
that are on each and every node,
and then you have
two possible layers,
two possible ways you can
write your metrics data, right.
The top one is the
open source format.
The Prometheus collector
gets all the data,
then it uses own
storage, and you
can present it either in
Prometheus or in Grafana.
I'm sure if you're using
any on premise solution,
you're very familiar with this.
And then you have Stackdriver.
Stackdriver does the same,
but it has the Stackdriver
Prometheus collector, so
it collects all of the data
from Prometheus.
But on top of that, it's also
getting some electric data
and metadata, right.
And again, you can
say in Stackdriver,
you are monitoring UI or
you can graph it in Grafana.
So that's it, that's the story.
And now, for the
rest of the talk,
I would like to
invite to the stage
JD Velazquez and
Shoucong Chan, who
are going to talk about how
we can see it in practice.
That's for you.
JD VELASQUEZ: Thank you, Jerzy.
Hello, everybody.
So we want to tell you and give
you a demo of how all of this
works.
But before we do that,
let's try to orient
ourselves a little bit.
Before we go to demos, put
on the slides again, please.
We'll try to orient ourselves a
little bit on what application
we have here, to give
you a sense of what
it is that we're doing here.
So this is a simple Java
application some of you
may be familiar with.
It's a pet clinic.
It's a veterinary clinic.
Who here has pets?
Come on, a lot more
you have pets, yes?
But hopefully, your
veterinary clinic
is not using this application
to handle everything inside
because it's pretty buggy
and it has all the things,
but we're going to try to
solve those issues right now.
So this is, again, like I
said, just a simple pet clinic.
Imagine that you are an employee
on this veterinary clinic,
and you want to be able to
handle the visits from all
of your customers.
They're pet owners,
they have pets.
And you want to track what
sort of things they're doing,
the types of visit, the type
of veterinarians they have,
and so on.
So to orient ourselves
further in this application,
to really go into a hybrid
scenario, what we've
implemented here
to give you a sense
is an architecture like this.
We essentially
have a cluster that
has been deployed on
prem, Kubernetes cluster.
We have four
microservices here, doing
what they're supposed to
do, managing customers,
managing the visits, managing
the veterinarians in general.
And the same cluster
we have actually
deployed on Kubernetes engine on
GCP, and both of those clusters
communicate with the data
source, which is Cloud Spanner.
So that's essentially
the app, very simple.
Now, let's go to the demo
and we'll see this in action
specifically.
So, and you know, just to orient
ourselves a little bit further
and start to generate a
little traffic to this app,
let's go in and
use it just a bit.
Let's list the set of owners
that may exist already.
This business may not be doing
very well right now, since it
has no owners or very few.
Of course, it's a live demo.
What could go wrong?
There we go.
OK, so we have a
few owners already.
What we can do is, let's add a
new pet to one of those owners
so we get a sense of the
different services, what
they do.
Let's add a new pet to
this particular one.
Let's give it a name.
We of course want to know the
date of birth for that pet,
and then one type of pet.
I prefer dogs, but there's
of course, lots of cats.
Now, we can add visits.
We see that some of the
pets for this owner, they've
already visited the clinic.
And then do some things.
This new pet, we're going to
take him in for the first exam,
it's a physical
exam, and that's it.
Now we may ask you, of
course, to go in and generate
some traffic for this,
but instead of doing that,
let us just generate a little
bit of more traffic right now.
The idea here is, of course,
we want to scale up things
so that we can do some of the
troubleshooting scenarios.
So we just are going
to our on prem cluster,
and as you see here, we're just
executing a scaling command,
and we're just scaling
up that on prem cluster.
Now, we did that on one side.
Let's do it now
on the GK cluster,
on from Kubernetes engine.
So let's go to
our cloud console.
Let's connect to the cluster.
And when we do that,
we see our cloud shell.
It's got all of our
credentials properly.
And now what we want to do
is run the same command.
We're going to scale up the
Kubernetes engine cluster.
So this is essentially
what we need to do,
right, just generate
some traffic here,
and it will take maybe
another few seconds or so.
There we go.
Now both clusters should be
getting some traffic now.
This is internal,
but the same thing.
You might as well be
generating that traffic for us.
Now, what we want to
do is, what happens,
how do we get the
type of observability
you need to see your Kubernetes
environment, particularly
in a hybrid scenario.
So you can do a
couple of things.
If you're starting on prem,
most likely, like many of us,
we'll be using open
source software,
so very like you're probably
using Prometheus and Grafana
if you want to get metrics
and do alerts and maybe
some visualizations that
you can configure and so on.
And that's exactly
what we're doing here.
Now, if you want to
get some logs as well,
you may be using Elastic
Search or some other solution.
And maybe you want
other signals, so maybe
a bunch of other tools.
When Jerzy was asking
you, those of you
who actually have
many tools, that
was a large majority of you
that actually stayed up and then
came down when,
you know, actually
used many tools, altogether
to get this observability.
So let's go to our Prometheus
and Grafana instance
on prem, the one we set up.
This actually took very
little configuration.
All of these solutions
are available on our GCP
marketplace, and
you can just readily
use it, kind of like a
one click type of setup,
and get those running.
So what we will do, just
cheating here a little bit
to make sure that we
get the right password,
lets log in into
that Grafana instance
that we have set up for on prem.
And as that comes
in, OK, perfect,
that's our Grafana instance.
Now, out of the box, with
this type of solutions,
you get definitely some
type of observability.
If we look at the
list of things here.
We have several dashboards.
You may look at your clusters,
your namespaces, your pods,
and so forth.
Let's go specifically
to our cluster 1
to get some notion of
health that may exist here.
So now you can see some
particular scorecards.
And definitely we see
that traffic actually
spiked up a bit.
So our scaling is working.
And then down below we have
some metrics that we could then
further peruse.
This is based on namespaces.
I could go specifically
to one of a namespaces.
We go to the default one.
And then from there-- then
we can drill down into pods.
And maybe we have
a dozen pods or so
for this particular app here.
And then we can take a look
at more of those metrics--
CPU utilization, the limits
request, and so forth,
maybe the same thing
for memory and so on.
So this is the way in
which you-- if you're
using open-source and
for me using Grafana,
you would get that type
of basic observability
you need for your
own brand cluster.
Are we talking about hybrid?
So you want to do the same
for your Kubernetes Engine.
Now there's not-- you can have a
do-it-yourself type of solution
to do multi-cluster monitoring.
But out of a box you really
must create a separate Grafana
instance and put it on your
Kubernetes Engine side.
And so let's do that precisely.
Why don't we go to
our cloud console
and then run the
commands we need
and then logging
into our Grafana
instance for Kubernetes Engine?
Now good thing, of
course, I can do--
I can transfer all my
dashboard configurations.
And then we'll be there.
So we can see the same thing.
We have all the same
type of dashboards.
So let's do the same thing
with it for the other one.
Same type of scorecard and we'll
see the profile in a minute.
Hopefully the traffic is
working in the same way.
And yeah, we see slightly
different pattern.
But traffic is also scaling
up on the Kubernetes
Engine and the same thing.
We can scale down--
drill down further on
the default namespace,
go to our pods--
again the same type of
observability you would get.
You can configure these
dashboards as you wish
and then get something that
meets your needs specifically.
Now, as I said
earlier, many of you
actually are using
many different tools
to get the type of
observability you need.
And what we've heard
from many of you
here actually is that you don't
want to use that many tools,
that you want a single unified
solution to observe and get--
do proper monitoring and logging
of your Kubernetes environment
no matter where it runs.
Now whether it's running On-Prem
or running on GCP on Kubernetes
Engine or even if you're running
that Kubernetes deployment
on a GCE instance or maybe
even on a VM instance
or on another cloud
provider, you still
want to have that single
place where you can
monitor all of these things.
So this is where Stackdriver
Kubernetes monitoring comes in.
So Stackdriver Kubernetes
monitoring gives you very rich
and comprehensive observability
for your Kubernetes environment
no matter where it runs.
And what it does is actually
integrates metrics and logs
and events and metadata
in a single place
so that you don't have to
be going to different tools
to try to get that
observability precisely.
So let us see how
this works in action.
If we can go to Stackdriver
Kubernetes Monitoring, which
you can do by selecting the
monitoring link on your Cloud
console--
that takes you to the
Stackdriver monitoring
console here.
And from there, we're going
to choose the Resources menu.
And then go directly to the
Kubernetes monitoring console.
So this is a product we
just announced briefly.
And it's in beta right now.
And so we'd love for you to use
it and give us your feedback.
So first, this is the
Stackdriver Kubernetes
monitoring console.
Let's orient ourselves
a little bit here.
So first, you see the
event widget in the top.
That allows you, essentially,
to get information
from different
events, particularly
things that may be of
interest for your Kubernetes
environment.
It is actually a heat map.
So you have the more solid
lines is because there's
a higher frequency of events.
And the idea is for you
to correlate those events
with the state of your
cluster down below.
Now in the pane below precisely
you see the set of clusters.
Now, from the start, notice that
we already have observability
of the two clusters.
Our On-prem cluster
is already there.
And our GKE cluster
is also there.
Now, for deploying
the Stackdriver agents
on the On-Prem cluster,
it's really simple.
You just follow a
set of instructions.
And it's done.
So out of the box, you
get rich observability
for your hybrid
multi-cluster environment.
Now notice also that
here in this scenario
we surface a lot of key
information for you,
including the number of
incidents, pods that are ready,
memory and CPU utilization
with respect to your resources
and the limits that
you have configured.
Notice as well that
you've actually--
even though Kubernetes doesn't
have a hierarchy per se--
we're taking advantage
of Kubernetes' labels
to give you a pre-curated
hierarchies that
may be useful for you depending
on the role that you may have.
So if you're an SRE and
operater, for instance,
you may want to look at the
state of your infrastructure.
You want to make sure
that your nodes are
healthy and performant.
So that's what you
may be doing here.
But if you're a developer,
you may actually want to be--
and of course we want for you
to focus on writing your code
and look at your
applications-- so you
may be more
interested in looking
at it from the perspective
of your deployments
or your services, particularly.
So we can drill down from
a cluster to a namespace
to the services that you want.
Notice as well that
as we're doing this,
you can actually
drill down all the way
from your cluster in all of
these views all the way down
to a container.
And for each of these
Kubernetes objects,
you get very rich information.
So for instance, I
can go and inspect--
let's inspect a pod right now.
And I immediately
get several metrics.
I know that my pod is
ready and is running.
If there's any incidents open,
I can see it right there.
And then I start to get some
information on my metrics,
like CPU, memory, and so on.
All the way down--
and notice that
in the same place
as we move beyond
network usage, you'll
find that we also include logs.
So that goes back
again to this idea
of true and rich
observability, trying
to increase the signals
that are available to you
at the right context in the
right time and right Kubernetes
component.
So it is easier for you to
speed your root cause analysis
when you're trying to
resolve an incident
or to find things
when you're just
doing proactive monitoring.
So we see snippets of
logs are right here.
And I could even go
deep down into logging
to get more details here.
Now this is very much the
self-contained Kubernetes
monitoring.
But of course, you can use it
with all the other features
that Stackdriver has.
Jerzy mentioned before
that Stackdriver already
has a Prometheus collector.
So if you have a Prometheus
instrumentation already,
you can just have
that with Stackdriver.
All your metrics will be
ingested without a change.
And if you're not using any
Prometheus instrumentation yet
but you want to get access
to third party metrics--
let's say you have--
you're using Kafka, RabbitMQ,
or anything else on your app--
then you can ingest
those via Prometheus
and they'll be ready
in Stackdriver.
So the way we do that is if we
want to inspect those metrics
we can create custom charts
and custom dashboards.
Or you could go to
Metrics Explorer,
which is exactly the way you do
on demand type of inspection.
So here we can inspect all
of our Kubernetes objects
and all the metrics that
are available to you.
I can look at all the
Prometheus metrics.
You see the autocomplete
already expanding
on all the Prometheus metrics.
This is a Java app.
So let's look into
one particularly.
Let's do the JVM Memory Use
Bytes to get a sense here.
So all right.
There we go.
So lots of signals but
fast and available--
you get a sense for
what we have here.
Now the good thing is that
we've added a lot of dimensions
to these metrics.
So you can filter in group
by a lot of metadata,
including Kubernetes labels
and user-defined labels.
So let's try to do some here.
Let's filter by service name.
And well the service
name we can do--
notice that you get actually an
autocomplete of all the values
that apply to that label.
Let's do the API gateway.
Apply that.
OK, that's still
a lot of signals
but a little bit better.
We could still group
I and aggregate
maybe creative 95th
percentile or some sort.
But what we have here is
maybe the easiest thing
would be maybe do outlier mode.
We can then check the top end
objects that are of interest.
So why don't we do the top 5
containers by JVM memory use
bytes--
use megabytes.
So there we have it.
So that rapidly you can
easily develop a hypothesis
or just inspect
on demand and look
at particular metrics for any
of your Kubernetes components
and metrics available.
So this wraps up essentially
this proactive type
of monitoring.
Now all the other features
in Stackdriver including
multi-condition alerting
and everything else
are available to
you, including what
you may have seen
earlier in the keynote
when it's ready for
public consumption--
all the service monitoring stuff
and integration with eastoe
and so on.
So that's essentially for the
main console and community
is monitoring.
I'm going to switch
with Shoucong
now so that he can take us
through a troubleshooting
scenario.
SHOUCONG CHEN: All right.
Thanks, JD.
So this is Shoucong,
the tech lead
of our Kubernetes monitoring.
So I want to demo a
troubleshooting scenario.
So as a software engineer
or operation engineer,
one of the thing
the common scenario
you will probably encounter
a lot in your daily work
is when your
application receiving
a high volume of
traffic, your application
become less responsive or slow.
And so this is the scenario.
So as to recall it's like
when JD is doing his demo,
we generate some traffic against
both Kubernetes Engine cluster
and the on-prem cluster.
And while you were
watching the previous demo,
I, as an encore engineer, has
been paged by this incident,
by this traffic.
So as you can see
here from the email,
I have already receiving alerts.
It's like some of my container
are returning too many 500s.
Some of my services are
returning too many 500s.
So and in this email
report at the bottom,
it give me a View Incident
link, which redirect me
to Stackdriver Incident page.
So as you can see here--
so this is like where our
services are returning
too many 500 this is concerning,
because our customer may
experiencing this outage.
So I would like to resolve this
incident as soon as possible.
Let's go to the custom dashboard
for the My Hybrid PetClinic
app.
This is a custom dashboard
I pre-define before.
We add some charge
for some interesting
matches I care the most for
my PetClinic application.
For example, on
the first row there
are two charts for HTTP
request and HTTP errors.
And since this is a
Java application--
so I also draw two
charts for JVM metrics,
which is collected and
exported by Prometheus.
Besides that, I also draw
something like CPU limit
met utilization and memory
utilization and some container
restart, and something else.
So by looking at this
custom dashboard,
it gives me a very
good understanding
about what my
hybrid application--
what's their current states.
Let's look at the first chart.
As you can see, both my
Kubernetes Engine Cluster
and my on-prem cluster are
receiving a reasonable amount
of traffic, like
both around 300.
This is working as
intended, because this is
where my low balance conflicts.
I put half and halfway
on both cluster.
If I look at a second chart,
we can see all of my 500 arrows
are all coming from
On-Prem cluster.
It already give me a very strong
signal that something is wrong.
It's in my On-Prem cluster.
As a natural reaction,
I may want to dive
deeper into the on-prem
cluster and figure out
what's happening there.
But our SIE best
practice tell me
I should mitigate and
contend the issue first.
And the best choice here is
to drain my On-Prem cluster
and fail over its traffic
to somewhere else.
And since I have two
cluster, failing over two
Kubernetes Engine
is a natural choice.
But before I do that I want to
ensure the additional safety.
I want to make sure
my Kubernetes Engine
cluster can sustain the
load if [INAUDIBLE]..
So let's go to the
Kubernetes monitoring UI.
And let's take a look
at infrastructure
and expand the Kubernetes
Engine cluster.
So as you can see, there
are six nodes there.
Some of them are
reasonably busy,
like you can see
42% utilized, 43%.
But some of them
are quite empty.
So this give me a
confidence that even
I fail over my traffic
to Kubernetes Engine,
it can sustain.
So let's go ahead and do it.
So in this terminal,
JD will manually
drained the on-prem
cluster by scaling down.
And in the same time
we will switch back
to cloud shell for my
Kubernetes Engine Cluster.
And here we will scale
manually scale up
to failover the traffic.
So this step will probably take
about one or two minutes when
we are switching traffic from
one cluster to another cluster.
Let's go back to
the hybrid dashboard
and see what we
can observe there.
So as you can see here--
so our on-prem cluster's
traffic has already been drop.
And then the 500 race also
dropping and in a moment later
we will see the
Kubernetes Engine
cluster receiving more traffic.
So this give you a
little bit more time.
So in the real world it's
like draining the traffic--
will take some time.
OK.
So let's refresh again.
So let's [INAUDIBLE]
fresh one more time
and see what it can goes.
Yep.
As you can see here--
so our Kubernetes Engine cluster
has receiving more traffic.
And it will keep going up.
So I think in this moment as an
encore engineer, I'm fairly--
I'm reasonably confident
that the issue has
been mitigated and contained.
Now next step for
me is to figure out
what's happening in
this on-prem cluster
to prevent it-- to
resolve it and prevent it
from happening again.
Let's go to Kubernetes UI--
monitoring UI and
switch to service tab.
And that's open.
As you can see here we have
an open incident can call on.
That's [INAUDIBLE]
inside-- like what
what's the entity that
has the most issues.
And then you can
help us drill down
and then identify where we
should pay attention to.
So we can further go down
to the default namespace.
And there will be
the API gateway.
It's the thing that
will have the issue.
So let's inspect the
port of API gateway.
So as you can see here--
so for the first try
to contain a restart,
it doesn't have any restart.
It means probably my
container is healthy.
And memory utilization
is in a reasonable usage.
And CBO utilization
is high, about 80%.
But it is reasonable because we
are sending a lot of traffic.
And it is not crazy.
It's not like out
of the boundary.
So it doesn't stands
very suspicious.
Let's scroll down.
And storage usage is flat.
And network usage is high,
because the same-- we
are receiving a lot of traffic.
And so until now if looking
at a system metrics,
it doesn't tell
us anything that's
suspicious, because it
seems like my Kubernetes
application--
Kubernetes infrastructure
is running healthily.
Well, then what could
be the root cause?
At this moment the log
will help us a lot.
As you can see here
from the log rates,
we are receiving a lot of an
unreasonable amount of error
logs from what you have been.
As you can see,
there's about 40%
of error log has been returned
while during the incidence.
This is like-- is a very good
signal for me to make maybe--
my app is returning
some-- it has some back
and then reslowing some errors.
As you can see from
the log snippet below,
we already see some like
runtime exception has been
thrown by my Java application.
I want to understand a
little bit more details.
Let's click on the
Go To Login link.
And then go to
Stackdriver Logs Viewer
to have a more detailed look.
So this link will redirect
me to the Logs viewer, which
the [INAUDIBLE] specifically
for the single port
and restrict it to the time that
where this incident happened.
That matters the most to me.
As you can read
from here, there are
dozens of occurrence of
this runtime exception
has been thrown.
If we open one of
them, we can see
the error message is like,
"Unable to fetch detail
for Owner 1," which is
a runtime exception.
And it is a stack trace.
It will give us a very
good understanding
where all these excess
has been thrown.
If we scroll down, we
can see like this--
so this API gateway controller.
Let's see.
Yeah, this API gateway
control Java file in line 54
is throwing this error.
And I want to understand why
this error has being thrown.
Let's go to code.
So what it is doing
here is that he
will search for these
API gateway Java file,
because that's what
stack trace has tell us.
And then let's go
to the line 54.
Or use like, search.
So as you can see here,
there are three lines very
problematic.
Somebody has add these
three lines of code
to throw 500 after
tossing a coin.
So this is where my
code has a [INAUDIBLE]..
And so I'm going to--
so now I've identified
the root cause.
The thing for me-- next
step is to fix the bot,
redeploy the app
to on-prem cluster,
and then undrain
the on-prem cluster.
So my application will
be back to normal.
We are not going
to do this here,
but just to illustrate the idea.
So as you can see from this
troubleshooting scenario,
stackdriver of
Kubernetes monitoring it
integrates a metric
log metadata and event.
It can give you
the observability
you'll need to monitor
and troubleshoot
your hybrid Kubernetes
application.
And let's switch
back two slides.
And so if you want to
know a little bit more
about how you want to
observe and troubleshoot
your hybrid
Kubernetes application
and how to provision your
Kubernetes application better,
here are some related
talks you can attend.
And now lets welcome back
our teammates Jerzy and JD.
Now we open up for questions.
And maybe the time
is-- we're limited.
If you have more questions,
we can go to the hallway.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]